el peor accidente ferroviario en más de
cuatro décadas el choque de un tren con
un camión hizo que la máquina saliera de
los rieles y perdiera el control varios
vagones quedaron completamente
destrozados
poco a poco socorristas y bomberos han
logrado acceder al interior del túnel
donde varias personas quedaron atrapadas
y estamos muy tristes de que este
accidente haya ocurrido el primer día de
estas largas vacaciones muchas personas
resultaron heridas o murieron mi gente y
yo estamos profundamente afligidos
cuando recibí la noticia esta mañana
tuve una conversación con el primer
ministro su tseng-chang ambos hemos
instruido a los departamentos
relacionados para que reaccionen el
primer ministro su y otros dos ministros
se han ido rápidamente a hualien ahora
estoy aquí para supervisar el trabajo de
rescate y asegurarme de que se resuelvan
las cosas
si el tren viajaba a lo largo de la
montañosa costa este de taiwán en el
condado de hualien un popular destino
turístico famoso por sus túneles durante
el trayecto un camión se desvío de la
carretera y cayó en los rieles del tren
a los pasajeros que lograron ser
evacuados salieron por el techo y
ventanas los heridos fueron trasladados
a hospitales de toda la región
y muchas personas quedaron aplastadas
debajo de los asientos debido a la
colisión y había muchas personas en la
parte superior del tren así que los de
abajo fueron presionados aplastados y
perdieron el conocimiento al principio
todavía respondían a los llamados pero
yo supongo que perdieron el conocimiento
después el accidente ocurrió en un día
festivo cuando la gente viajaba a casa
para el festival religioso de barrido de
tumbas las autoridades iniciaron una
investigación para esclarecer los hechos